hey guys it's Kalei and also don't ask
the clean fit and during this unexpected
quarantine season I decided to try
another challenge so being that we're
stuck at home I've been trying to find
certain ways to keep myself active
motivated keep my body warm and it's
kind of hard when you don't have the
right equipment so unfortunately I
looked on Amazon
tried to find some dumbbells some weight
kettlebells and because all of you guys
are on the same wave they're sold out so
with that being said that's not gonna
stop me from being active though my goal
is to find as many household items as I
can to actually get a decent workout in
every single day for a week I'm gonna
try and find something in the house that
I can use and ideally I'm gonna find
some items tools whatever that you also
may have as well so that we can do this
together so for day one I ended up using
my couch I'm literally on it 24/7 so I
thought why not it's available it's
heavy enough so that I can actually get
something really good going
make sure to bend your knees at a
30-degree angle lift your chest up and
straighten your lower back to avoid
injury lying on the floor with your arms
on either side you're going to use one
foot to waist your hips and squeeze your
glutes for the leg press you want to
pinch the platforms and your heels and
forefoot to ex-gang anything aren't your
ideal bench press but inhale as you lift
then exhale while you lower back down
slowly stay tuned typical cleaning day
at my house but I use this handy dandy
tool right here to go ahead and get the
job done and maybe we can get a workout
in as well
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready am I ready for what we are
gonna be doing worked out 2/3 vac use is
this what you told me to take the vacuum
yes I need you to be in the same
position I hate you so day three was a
laundry day and I was literally dreading
it cuz I knew I had so much laundry to
do but it ended up being was hefty hefty
weight that I used for my walking lunges
my brother was also in his room all day
so I called him down and I was like
you're gonna help me with this laundry
and then I had him run up and down the
stairs and it was so funny because he
was like enough is enough faster up
again but then it dawned on me that I
should make this a family occasion cuz
everybody needs to be active in this
house so on day four I ended up finding
something so ancient so I just got back
into the Forbidden Lands and notice the
parents room and I realized that my dad
has his boom box but I knew that stereos
were heavy because you would see back in
the day they would hold them on the
shoulders like oh oh doing it you know
and I was like I know that they were
getting a workout every time they wanted
to pick up that stereo and look cute so
I'm gonna do three sets of ten real
quick before they even notice cuz
they're very distracted and I'm just
gonna sneak right back out
[Music]
like something mr. robot I know you
think this is funny
[Music]
so today I'm gonna be helping my mom
cook I'm gonna be your little sous chef
mom are you excited so we're gonna be
making I'm so excited to eat that okay
it's really good she was a little
irritated and she's like this is not
what I signed up for
how about leave it alone and um I'll do
them the way I so you're gonna be bored
and then okay
so the pros are one I got to use my
creativity to even find items to work
out with I know that sometimes it's as
easy as getting a dumbbell getting a
jump rope etc etc but when you don't
have that you have to use your brain to
try and figure out what can I use
instead so I really enjoyed using my
creativity to find item number two it
was cost-efficient like I literally
spent no money no money I still have
money in my wallet and number three I
got to spend time with my family a lot
of times when you're secluded when
you're in a quarantine you get used to
being by yourself being in your room or
being in your safe space and not
communicating with everybody else in the
house so this was an opportunity for me
to not only get them to enjoy something
that I enjoy but also for us to have a
cute little moment one of the challenges
was that it was very difficult to find
the items initially like I was like what
do I use a candlestick like I'm not sure
but then when I actually sat down and
thought about it and really explored
around my house I ended up finding
really good appliances to use the second
challenge that I faced was that
unfortunately depending on the item or
the appliance that I used it definitely
limited the type of workouts I could do
so a lot of the workouts were very
focused or heavily focused on legs and
so now my legs are really sore but we
did find some that were forearms as well
but I didn't get to do any ABS so I
would love to be able to incorporate ABS
and maybe I'll be able to try and find
something eventually like maybe a towel
or something but I didn't get to do that
in this challenge anyways I'd love to
know what you guys are doing to stay
active in the comments below until next
time stay clean and Stacey bye guys
[Music]